hey 42 here in order to get married in
Kenya the groom's family has to provide
a dowry of at least 10 cows to the
bride's family
welcome to before Beverly Hills became
home to the rich and famous the area was
better known for its lima beans the
Vatican City is now home to the Pope and
all his predecessors but not before the
14th century popes used to live in the
Lateran palace in Rome and even in
France for a brief period in the state
of Idaho you are prohibited by law to go
fishing on the back of a camel or a
giraffe a building in New York has been
built out of mushrooms the mushrooms are
grown in a brick mold and then set in a
building the longest continuous sidewalk
in the world is along Bayshore Boulevard
in Tampa Florida in Vermont billboards
are illegal to insure that drivers and
passengers can freely admire the natural
beauty Andrew Jackson was the only u.s.
president to have the national debt paid
in full the procrastinators Club of
America's newsletter is called last
month's newsletter Philip Morris wants
running out acknowledging smoker's cough
they claimed it was caused by smoking
brands over than Philip Morris
University of Louisville police arrested
a man for stealing the book titled
resolving ethical issues and trying to
sell it to the bookstore 26 miles of
unwrapped steel was used to construct
China's huge bird's nest stadium making
it the largest steel structure in the
world
America's first Air Force was equipped
with five hot air balloons and 50
servicemen New Hampshire is the only
u.s. state that does not lawfully
require drivers to wear safety belts
whilst operating a motor vehicle
George Washington grew marijuana at his
farm those doves released it weddings
and other formal ceremonies
actually white homing pigeons true
ringneck doves are bred to be kept as
pets and rarely survive out of captivity
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you